that's the worst human experience a
human being can go through lasting oh
yeah yeah I don't know why they do it
the way they do it especially the live
ones mm-hmm they do it live I know
Warner Brothers does it how did walk us
through I like it live because I just
had one for CBS this year and I did not
like that it was on tape because I need
to meet and charm I have to be that in
the ride I like in that way no because
what I like to do is this I like to go I
need a couple of shots you fart yep okay
well excuse me would be suffice excuse
me that's my phone okay yeah don't do
that again
yeah because now I don't even know what
I'm talking about you need a couple of
shots yeah I know I was kidding couple
of shots what do you mean like like I
need this no idea takes I need to you
know action and I so Jimmy can I do it
again mm-hmm I need that okay because if
I don't have it
Yeah right then if I I don't have a
[ __ ] I need a what do you call it
besides that side a safety net oh very
good though for improv yeah do you add
it information yeah correct but yeah
yeah give me another one
I need a oh those cookies look - ha ha
very good
you think rounding classes no no give me
100 quantum physics excuse me would you
take classes sir would you take classes
on from Korea Seoul Korea oh yeah first
problem with this is the books too big
very good if George likes improv jobs
fun game huh that's all improv is Ango
yeah yeah yeah yeah a quest and then the
rule is always what you had you can't
deny no yeah so if somebody says I got
you a gift
you're supposed to add information but I
like to deny
Bobby I got you a gift what does nothing
in your hand there's nothing there and
see and see and then I go home and I
could think about them you know it was
me yeah yeah here you go Bobby
Wow you got nothing not since your shirt
Oh
see what she did he saved it by adding
no below would you say that yeah why
keep going alright so nuts this is your
shirt that's there's nothing there but
oh my god where'd your shirt go what he
just did why would my hands like you
have carpal tunnel yeah father yeah no I
made it about my dad that's the reason
why it's scary the test is because
you've talked about this but I know
people don't want to hear about our show
business but you know how much you're
between you and another guy yeah and you
know how much of money you're gonna lose
oh yeah
if you don't get it so do they make you
do they give you the offer and you see
the number before you actually test them
you see the number you plan your future
yeah in your head you go okay yes the
thing that could happen like I don't
know if they have a cribs now but I
could do one good rumor rosenbaum I
attested from her show as soon as I
opened my mouth I knew I wasn't gonna
get hit really yeah the last time I just
for Peter Roth was for some others to
think I tested for as soon as I opened
my mouth I knew I was gonna get it so
it's gotta be in your head though cuz
you're just you seem like you test
through terrible now you test through
the roof there's no way audience I love
support